In Germany, authorities offer a reward for information...
...leading to the arrest of a Tunisian man...
...suspected of involvement in the Berlin truck attack,...
...identifying him as 24-year-old Anis Amri.
In Turkey, President Tayyip Erdogan...
...says there's no doubt the assassin who killed Russia's ambassador to Turkey...
...was connected to the network of Muslim cleric, Fethullah Gulen.
At least 21 people are dead and almost 300 people were arrested...
...in the Democratic Republic of Congo during protests,...
...demanding that President Joseph Kabila step down.
In Gambia, Gambian president, Yahya Jammeh, says he will not step down...
...despite calls to hand over to the election winner, Adama Barrow.
And finally, a cargo plane crashed in eastern Colombia, killing five...
...while one person survived.